words take wings May 15 1918 and in the nation's
capital US Mayo heads for its first trip by air
the load is 136 pounds destination the city
of New York President Wilson adds prestige
and a letter to the event and chats with pilot
GL Boyle Boyle is off but he follows the wrong
railroad tracks and 25 miles south of Washington
cracks up at Belmont Park New York May 15 coast
master Thomas Patton hands 144 pounds of mail
for Washington to pilot Tory Webb destined to
do better than Boyle Patton commemorates the
occasion with a send-off speech on display
are the first stamps for US mail by air and
into the air goes the first airmail plane to
complete the scheduled flights an hour later at
busselton the Philadelphia terminus web plans for
refueling and the first hump is finished mechanics
checked the ship for necessary overhauling and
find it undamaged with pilot JC Edgerton that
controls the male wings its way to Washington
here is the completion of a 218 mile journey
by air the first of its kind in America
Edgerton and the mail come through
July 1924 and over San Francisco the
first transcontinental airmail reaches
its destination in flames flimsiest
postcards US pilots spanned the nation
in short hop relays and an inspired
nation applauds these brave pioneers
here's Burt Acosta celebrating with
Eddie Rickenbacker and friend the
post office Dallas 1926 first airmail
from Texas gets a rapid stamping and
heads for the plane and Chicago
here is pilot Herbert kindred for
the first time mail from the cattle
country wings toward the Windy City
airmail spends the sea from Miami a flying boat
arrives at Panama February 13 1929 at the end of
airmails first flight over open water the pilot
is Lindy just two years after his history-making
hop of the Atlantic yes it's Colonel Charles
a Lindbergh doing new wonders with wings